did you see the shocking images of the
ancient ruins of some Square structure
on Mars are we seeing the remains of a
long lost alien
civilization Chris Ramsey shared the
exciting news photo from a square
structure on Mars posted to Reddit it is
indeed real this image originates from
the Mars Global surveyor Mars Orbiter
camera the original image can be viewed
through Arizona State University's Mars
image Explorer Joe Rogan's mind was
blown he said this is wild Elon replied
we should send astronauts to Mars to
investigate desert Ranger adds perhaps
the most interesting thing about this
structure is that it sits on the top
edge of a crater perhaps the site was
bombed and the foundation is intact
because the building was far from the
ground zero what was this structure and
what kind of explosion could have
destroyed a building so far from ground
zero and we have no such thing as a
perfect 90° angel in nature this is
fascinating there are no squares in
nature only people thus far create
squares have there been beings older
than us from Mars humans invented
squares before we were there they did
not exist as it was literally imposs
possible for a square to form without
human interaction
aliens but there's a community note that
says context both of these images were
edited to make the square shape clearer
the original can be seen here so here
are the two images that were circulated
the one on the right was clearly edited
it's got some digital lines on it but
the one on the left was edited as well
mainly by adjusting the contrast in such
to emphasize the square here's the
original image you can still make out a
square shape and here it is on asus's
Mars Orbiter camera image
Explorer now if you're around my age you
probably remember something very similar
when you were growing up in the 1980s
because back in the 80s we were shown a
photograph of a mysterious face on Mars
the photo was taken in 197 6 imagine
taking a photo of Mars and you see an
enormous face staring right back at you
this we were told suggests that there
was once Life on Mars for this face must
be the result of
intelligence unfortunately for the alien
hunters higher resolution photos were
taken in 1998 and 2001 and it turns out
that the face didn't look like a face at
all but here's what I find interesting
about all of this if we see a mountain
on Mars that looks vaguely like a face
when the Shadows are just right we start
talking about aliens we associate the
structure of a face with intelligent
design and the more it looks like a face
the more we'll think it must have been
designed people stopped talking about
the Mars face when better images showed
that it doesn't actually look like a
face if better images had shown that it
looks even more like a face than we
realized from the 1976 image we would
have been more impressed and people
would have become more convinced that
the face was made by an intelligent
designer but here we are on planet Earth
and we see faces all around us every day
real faces and we're told that only
stupid people think that these faces
were ultimately the work of an
intelligent
designer when we see something on Mars
that looks vaguely like a square we
talking about intelligence but here's a
composite electron micrograph of part of
the motor in a bacterial flugum these
are parts of bacteria and we're told
that only stupid people think these
structures were ultimately the work of
an intelligent designer think about this
as you're watching this video right
now how many things that you see on your
screen right now don't require a
Creator the books
someone definitely had to make them the
shelves someone had to make them the Sid
Barrett painting obviously had a Creator
the little wooden Arc model that came in
my artsa box had to be made my glasses
my shirt my necklace my watch my ring
all obviously and indisputably made
there's a fake plant right beside me
oddly enough if I tell you the plant is
fake you'll conclude that someone made
it if I tell you the plant is real many
of you will conclude that no one made it
even though a real plant is massively
more complicated than a fake plant so
since this plant is fake what's the only
thing you see in this video that we're
assured wasn't created me a human being
far more complicated than everything
else you see right now combined and
that's including what ever device you're
using to watch this
video anything you see on your screen
right now apart from me is a joke
compared to any living thing the
simplest living cell is more
sophisticated than a thousand squares on
Mars so why do people start inferring
design when they see a rough outline of
a square on Mars but we're told only
morons would infer design when we
examine the most sophisticated things we
know about in the entire
Universe two main reasons first years
ago we were told by smart people in
positions of authority over us that
smart people have figured out that life
wasn't created and we believed these
people because they knew way more than
us back then by the time we could read
and study and examine the evidence for
ourselves we'd already been programmed
not to see design when it was staring us
right in our faces far more than the
imaginary Mars face ever stared at us
second we're just really familiar with
the things we see around us we're used
to them we're not used to squares or
faces on Mars so we find them surprising
but we're used to things on earth so
they're not surprising and since they're
not surprising we're not as desperate to
find
explanations but did you know that if
you depr RVE your senses of things for a
while they'll eventually become
surprising again it happened to me 30
years ago here's a fun story you've
never heard in 1995 I was convicted of
malicious wounding and when you're
convicted they put you in a holding cell
with other inmates for processing they
have to figure out what to do with you
in the jail before they send you off to
prison so a lady comes to the bars of
the cell and starts asking questions now
before she got there I was on a roll
telling stories to the four or five
other guys in that holding cell I don't
remember what I was talking about but
they were cracking
up then the lady comes to the bars and
has some questions for me because she
knows I've been in a mental hospital so
she asks why I was in a mental hospital
what was I diagnosed with and the entire
time I'm answering these questions the
guys behind me are giggling giggling
like oh man this guy's nuts then the
lady asks have you ever attempted she
wanted to know if I'd ever tried to end
myself and I say huh have I I hadn't but
for some reason I liked giving people at
the jail incorrect
information what were they going to do
lock me up so she becomes more concerned
and says how did you go about attempting
that and I say I jumped off a bridge
again I didn't it was actually my
brother's dad who jumped off a bridge
and he died but the story was still
fresh in my mind so I used it I said I
jumped off a bridge she replied and what
happened and I said uh I guess I
survived
obviously guys behind me were almost
falling off their benches listening to
this
long story short the guards put me in
isolation with nothing but a paper gown
and a roll of toilet paper they knew I'd
be going to a mental hospital to see if
I should be in jail or in a mental
hospital so they decided they just keep
me in isolation until I was evaluated so
I spent about 3 months in isolation they
let me out a couple of times per week to
take a shower the shower was right
beside my cell so I'm seeing very little
of anything for months
on a side note I've been diagnosed with
antisocial personality disorder I'm
considered more mentally tough than
normal people things that affect normal
people don't affect me nearly as much
but I can tell you if you spend months
in isolation you start losing your mind
I went on this brief tangent to help you
understand how they're trying to break
Tommy in the UK I can guarantee you he's
losing his mind right now
but after a few months they told me they
were taking me to Central State
psychiatric hospital they put me in
shackles all I had seen for months was
wall wall wall bars and on the other
side of the bars wall and suddenly I was
in a police van and I got to see the
world again for the first
time everything was amazing the sun the
sky clouds trees stop signs sidewalks
people Bridges it was all new to me and
I was astonished at
everything about 6 months later I was in
the same isolation cell once again this
time because I wasn't eating I wasn't
eating because I was trying to outfast
this Christian but the psychiatrist
thought I was trying to starve myself to
death and yet again I had no desire to
give her accurate
information I'd been in the for a while
wall wall wall bars this time however I
didn't need to see the sun the sky
clouds or anything beyond my cell I
didn't need trees or flowers to be
amazed everything became amazing the
walls the bars my bunk hands eyes
everything I realized that there's more
to the world than my atheism could
account for if you don't know what
happened next you can watch my video how
God destroyed my atheism but it took
being completely Stripped Away from life
as usual to undo the programming I'd
received all my
life you're made to recognize design
you're made to recognize the signs of
your creator for some reason you turn it
on when you see something that looks
like a face on
Mars but you spend your entire life
being trained to turn it off when you
see a real face on
Earth don't let anyone rob you one of
your greatest and most important
abilities
[Music]